I apologize that you have to hear from
me all three days and for a whole half
an hour now or right before lunch so I'm
gonna keep you all trapped in here so
apologize found a little scattered
they've been running around for the
conference a little more more work than
I had initially thought but let's go for
it so this is a quick about me it's my
face and my name you can basically find
me everywhere on the internet with that
tag RAK t you are are you know Instagram
Twitter Facebook website email anything
just put that and you'll probably find
me so the bottom there is basically sums
up my life I say I'm a data scientist
it's on my business card but I'm really
a data engineer in you know most of the
time and then PhD is kind of what I do
on the weekends should be graduating in
May hopefully so this basically is the
inspiration for this talk and you can
see the title kind of comes from it well
okay so that's not completely true this
was the inspiration for the thing that
inspired my talk and I'll show you that
actually right now so basically this is
an interesting tweet by Gary Bernhardt
he's a dude who speaks a lot basically
about programming
he gives lots of talks he runs
conferences and all that stuff and this
was really at the peak hype of Big Data
you look at this tweet was in 2015 so
this is like peak I need Hadoop I have
this big data I need some no sequel
MapReduce spark all of these things
everybody's like oh my gosh I have big
data I need to do this stuff and then he
came out with this tweet that's like
well you know your data probably
actually fits in RAM on a single machine
so that's what I'm gonna convince you of
today and probably make some people mad
but that's the point
and I'll have a very sarcastic tone for
a lot of this but that's also the point
so so let's click this oh not that let
me go ahead and click this link oh you
get to see all my notes great so this
was the thing that I
[Music]
it's over there okay so this was the
thing that really inspired this talk
it's this little website somebody posted
and then I was like interesting okay my
date has five gigs that makes sense that
fits in RAM right 50 gigs ok maybe not
your laptop but it fits in RAM somewhere
500 gigs ok all right
that fits in ram to 5000 ok ok that that
fits in Ram right 50 thousand ok maybe
it doesn't now but 5,000 gigs of RAM
that's 5 terabytes there's a computer
out there that has five terabytes of RAM
and you could load your data into Ram
you don't need a cluster and if you
click this link it just brings you to
some big mainframe that cost lots of
money but technically Fitz and Ram so
that's the inspiration for this talk and
mainly I'm gonna focus on machine
learning research data prep and then
model building for machine learning
research because I do machine learning
research so all of this is gonna be very
biased towards my own experiences data
sets that I've used and just the
experiences that I've had so hopefully I
can relay some of that information to
you also partially inspired by this talk
was this other talk that I saw by
Eduardo arena de la rubia at the time he
was the CEO and founder of Domino data
lab I think he's moved on to something
else since then but this was at strata
in New York I think in 2017 completely
different topic was not talking about
Ram or whatever what he was talking
about automated data science tools which
is a actually a very fantastic talk if
you want to go watch that but because
all riley is dumb you have to pay for it
so sorry anyway he gave this a random
rant at the end I think somebody asked
the question about something but
basically his rant was like don't use
spark for machine learning and I'm sorry
for all of the data pricks and spark
people that are here
I love spark I'm a certified developer I
go to all the conferences spark has his
place and cluster computing has his
place it's very good and fantastic but
he was basically saying don't use it for
a machine
learning and at the time because I was a
big spark fanboy I was like what this
guy is no this doesn't make any sense
but then I started to do more things I
did some more research and found that
okay maybe there is something to this
maybe I can do all of my machine
learning research on a single machine
but I'll do my data prep or whatever on
a cluster so again before I make people
too mad I want to still say that cluster
computing has its place but maybe not
now with Nvidia rapids I don't know it
was a new thing for me but Costa
confusing has a place you know big data
and there's a reason that this whole
history of Hadoop and MapReduce and
spark and all this stuff happened
because it works and it works really
well it helps you handle lots of data it
helps a lot with streaming data and all
that good stuff so I'll start off with
that before I make people too mad so
there's really two types of people here
that I think I'm talking towards will
just say this half of the room are the
data scientists analysts people who
traditionally use your laptop or a
single machine to do computing and now
you're running into data set size
problems things are taking too long
right the other side of this is our Big
Data engineers people who have been
doing Hadoop and and MapReduce and spark
for 10 years now and I'm gonna try to
convince you that maybe you don't need
to use those tools for everything and
these are the two things that I want you
to take away because you know all the
little details may you may forget it or
you can reference the slides afterwards
but these are the two ideas I just want
to give to you like an inception style
thing just take these ideas and plant
them in your brain and then do whatever
you wish with with them after that first
the cloud is your friend you want to use
the cloud it's very nice and your laptop
is stronger than you think so you can do
a lot more on your laptop and you
probably think you can and hopefully I
can show you some tips and tricks to be
able to do that so let's get going first
cloud is your friend so use the cloud
for people who are not super familiar
with the cloud I will freeze over this
basically there's not really a cloud
it's not just a magical thing that's out
there that gives you just like unlimited
processing power or whatever the cloud
is somebody else's computer
they manage they handle putting all the
hardware together they handle the power
and all that stuff you just say hey I
want this machine for two hours okay
they give you the machine than you do
stuff with it but really it's the same
as your computer and that's pretty much
that
I love the sticker it's in our cloud
services and devops team teams room so
real quick here's a slide you don't have
to read all this I'll highlight what you
need to know but I'm familiar with
Amazon so I'm just going to talk about
Amazon you know Microsoft and Google
also have very great cloud platforms and
these you know ideas will transfer to
those cloud platforms as well this is
just showing you there's some different
types of instances that you can get from
AWS some that are built for computing
some of them are built for memory some
that have GPUs storage anything you need
but what I want to show you is this
right here
I know it's small but I'm going to read
it for you up to seven hundred and sixty
eight gigabytes of memory per instance
so more likely than not your data set is
going to be smaller than seven hundred
and sixty eight gigs of ram probably so
you can launch a machine and then do
whatever you want to with that also what
if you're like oh my gosh I don't need
Ram I'm doing deep learning I'm super
cool I get to look at images and all
that stuff well you also can get GPUs ah
GPUs yeah sorry Nvidia you don't have to
buy they're in GPUs you can just rent
them of course these are going to be
like the top tier like super fast thing
that just came out yesterday they have
to pay five thousand dollars for these
are going to be a little bit older GPUs
but again don't read this whole thing
what I want to show you these two guys
you get a GPU you get a CPUs you get
some RAM ninety cents per hour so if
you're tinkering around playing with
something on the weekend you only pay
ninety cents per hour you can actually
get discounted rates from Amazon usually
when I launch that machine I pay like
thirty cents per hour for it so it's not
bad okay so hopefully with these two
slides I've convinced you to use the
cloud the cloud is awesome how do I do
this thing well I have another talk for
you to watch this is a git repo I
presented a talk about this probably
around a year ago actually in this venue
as well
and this is just some helpers again
basically this is library I wrote for
myself to do my research then I'm like
other people might be find this helpful
maybe they don't but I'm posting it
anyway so this shows you a couple ways
where you can just like get a Jew per
donor notebook going in the cloud
SSH onto it and then use it as if it was
your own laptop and if you want to grab
a quick pic or whatever of that link
again these slides will be posted later
also see you just use this little
username you'll find me anywhere so you
can find that on the Internet okay
moving along so basically I'm just going
to have a bunch of slides with like four
words on them and then we're going to
talk about it first thing is use your
libraries basically again for this side
of the room that already uses Python it
are there the data scientists analysts
more likely than not you have your
favorite tools you want you use
scikit-learn you use pandas you use Rd
plier all that good stuff use them your
most effective with those tools go ahead
and use them don't bother learning some
complicated cluster computing thing that
doesn't do everything that you need to
you're gonna have to go into C or go
into like some Scala code to actually
write some custom stuff to do what you
want use the libraries you already know
and then just get a machine with oh
sorry about that and then just get a
machine with 500 gigs of ram and then
you're off to the races and and the
reason I say that is because cluster
computing and cluster programming
distributed programming is hard right
it's all you have to think about a lot
of things you have to think about
different machines where you send the
memory you know are they all the same
machine blah blah blah blah blah when
you have one computer it's much easier
to program on that you have one computer
so here I want to show you again no
offense to SPARC we got spark on the
left here this is their entire library
of machine learning fits on one page
this side is I can't learn and you see I
have to scroll and make this little gift
thing because they have a ton of
algorithms because scikit-learn is a
dedicated machine learning library SPARC
there's a whole bunch of stuff there's a
whole bunch of stuff really well also
those machine learning and the machine
is fine they kind of based their API on
the scikit-learn API anyway
but you already have all this stuff
you're going to be limited over here and
it's going to be more complicated and
then how do you transfer your models
blah blah blah blah so if you're ready
no scikit-learn just keep using it just
get a bigger machine okay but what if
you're like Aaron no you don't
understand I just have too much data I
have so much data
it's huge data I need cluster computing
I couldn't possibly do that on a single
machine but so what I'll say to that is
do you really need all the data is what
I'm saying
first of all do you really have more
than one terabyte of data if you do
you're probably Facebook or Nvidia and
you have your own tools to handle that
those people I'm not talking to you I'm
talking to you at a you know finance
company I'm talking to you at some you
know software company just trying to
build some models help your business do
some cool things you don't have more
than a terabyte of data
probably not but okay so Big Data
revolution all these people are like
yeah all the data more data means better
models we need more of it we need more
and more more or more so then they're
like yeah okay then now they finally
convinced the business they're like yes
we need more data we need a cluster we
need to do this stuff so then the
business is like go ahead use all that
data build me a model with all of it
then they turn into this guy because as
soon as they try to do it they're like
oh all the data that's kind of hard yeah
it is kind of hard especially again when
you're trying to program distributed
machine learning algorithms so basically
what I'm trying to say here is even if
you have a lot of data you probably
don't need all of it for a machine
learning algorithm you probably can do
fancy thing called sampling yes and
statisticians have been doing this for
years sampling more likely than that you
can sample your data and again you're a
data scientist you know all the fancy
math to do that to prove that only ten
percent of your data is needed to prove
whatever you're trying to prove so more
likely than not you can sample your data
and they these are some like very
cryptic graphs because it's from some
super top-secret research that has not
yet been published so I had to obfuscate
the axes but basically what I'm showing
here is on the x-axis is data set size
it's the same data set you have some big
data set first we sample it down to
different sizes and it's backwards sorry
so we're decreasing so the smallest data
set is over here so on the left here we
have the AUC which is the model
performance and so we can see if these
top two guys okay they stay pretty
consistent all the dots are pretty much
within the error bars so the models are
essentially the same
and then this guy actually gets like way
better as the data size gets smaller
which is very interesting here on the
right side we have the cost and that
goes obviously right as soon as the data
set size decreases you need less time
you need less CPUs to actually do your
computation this cost is based on
amazon's pricing for four different
machines so yeah basically you reduce
your cost and you make your model better
of course you're gonna sample because
now you can try a bunch of different
things you're not stuck waiting days and
days and days for an algorithm to finish
running and especially in binary
classification scenarios it's really
interesting because I do a cancer risk
prediction that's what I do for my
research so most people not going to get
cancer small percentage of people will
get cancer so in my data set it's less
than 1% of people that are in the
positive class meaning they're high risk
for cancer so why do I need all 99% of
that data just throw away randomly some
of those instances because more likely
than not people that don't get cancer
there will be groups of people that look
very similar and all you're doing is
wasting CPU cycles by trying to build a
model on all of those negative instances
there are way half of them there are
wait 80% of them something then you can
run stuff a lot faster cool all right oh
this is just a blank slide for me to
catch my breath so all right
next next one file formats are very
important and this is something that I
found a lot at my company doing a lot of
the data engineering work is that file
formats are really really crucial and
here are a couple examples of some file
formats on the Left we have our
traditional kind of big file formats and
then here we have our nicer file formats
so I'll walk through some of these
databases right it's a regular thing
that you're going to get from any
application any kind of relational
database in Excel right but none of us
use Excel because we're good data
scientists right we write code for
everything nobody uses Excel here and
then CSV files it's the same thing CSV
files are just text so when you have a
bunch of text sitting on a file it takes
up way more space than it needs to
you take that text you load it into RAM
it's taking up way more space than it
needs to even and Rim so it's not
written on the slide here but just
remember this you want a binary columnar
oriented data format and Wes will talk
more about that tomorrow with arrow but
that's really what you want so binary
because you can compress that data is
going to be stored in a much more
efficient manner and you want columnar
because usually when you're doing data
operations you're operating on a whole
column of records rather than each row
individually so also parquet is like my
favorite thing ever because I found that
our K files are much smaller and they
run faster so parquet is an Apache
project spark supports this natively a
lot of library support this pandas does
now thanks to arrow basically that is a
columnar binary data format it's a self
describing data format which means the
actual data files have the metadata in
them the column names and the column
types so now you're not dealing with the
stupid stuff would see it's bees or
you're like oh what type is it as a
string is it into whatever park' handles
that for you feather is a nice format
also that came out of arrow that helps
you send data between different
languages it was more of like the
initial prototype for arrow so like our
and Python can read the same feather
file and get the same stuff and hdf5 is
a cool thing
that I won't talk about much just just
write these down and google them later
that's really all this talk is for so
here's some code real fast I'm gonna
link to a notebook at the end too with
this code but here's some random file
that I made it's not actually random
it's real data but this file you know
just to do on a laptop 11 megabytes
right I read this in it's a tab
delimited text file and then write it
out as a park a file didn't do anything
to it didn't touch the data didn't you
know sample it or anything
same exact data now 2.7 megabytes so if
you're bad at math that's a five-fold
increase so that helps a lot and the
compression might get better if you use
different compression libraries and
depending on what is inside of your data
so hopefully I proved to you that you
can use park' now also I don't have time
to go into this but hdf5 is a very handy
file format it's really good at like
storing some metadata it's really good
as well as if you need to pull out
specific samples of your data it'll
actually index it and you can pull out
samples really fast I have a little just
here on github basically I had an 80 gig
CSV file and I didn't want an 80 gig CSV
file so I wrote some code that will take
that file convert it to an HD f5 file
but my machine that I was using did not
have 80 gigs so I had to do was take
chunks of the CSV continually append it
to the hdf5 but then you get one big
hdf5 file that I think ended up being
like 10 or 20 gigabytes so a little
easier to manage but just you know some
code right there next up sparse matrices
so sparse matrices are cool because
they're they're used a lot again this is
just because what I encounter in my
research I deal with a lot of
categorical data so when you have
categorical data machines need to read
numbers snap strings for machine
learning so I you have to convert those
the easiest way is do one hot encoding
if you have 10 values that you're
recording in a particular column you
create 10 new columns and then for every
row only one of those columns will be 1
or not
but what happens when you do that is you
get a lot of zeros especially if you
have thousands and thousands of
different columns with hundreds of
values in each and what that creates is
a sparse matrix so a regular table a
regular matrix rows and columns you have
numbers filled out through it is
recorded in a dense manner
mathematically a dense matrix is a
matrix that has a smart mathematically a
sparse matrix has more zeros than non
zeros in it but in computer terms it's
how you're storing the data so a dense
matrix will store every single value
versus where a sparse matrix will only
store the nonzero values but what it
does instead is restores an index value
and then the actual value of your thing
rather than every single value and I'll
show you how that helps so again here
are some packages for you to write down
in Google later if you don't know them
smart matrices are very very supported
in Python you can create them with side
PI pandas actually has a sparse data
frame which is really really handy
because you can actually assign column
names and types to the the sparse matrix
which is awesome and so I could learn a
bunch of the algorithms actually support
sparse data so just check out the
documentation when you're building those
models make sure it supports a sparse
matrix and then you're good to go
on the right side here are just a couple
of the actual file formats that can
actually materialize and persist sparse
matrices to disk these are actually text
formats but it's handy because again
it'll store the index and then the
actual value index value index value
whatever
live SVM and rff you can look at it so
here I will approve to you again what
I'm saying here is some matrix if you go
through the notebook it'll make sense
completely you know where all the stuff
is coming from but here's some big
matrix and you see most of the values
are zeros that's all zeroes right we
look at look at the size of this it's
like five thousand rows by two thousand
columns multiply that together means
you're recording was it twelve million
data points and that's a pretty small
data set five thousand samples two
thousand columns not very big but you
already have twenty twelve million data
points but we'll use numpy and check the
non zero values we actually only have
56,000
real data points so that means we're
storing 12 million zeros for no reason
that's why we have sparse matrices so
here we use sci-fi and there's a sparse
package inside sci-fi we're gonna take
our little dense matrix here we're gonna
convert it to a sparse one and it tells
you hey you know here's how big your
matrix is and here's how many values you
have and you can actually save it into
numpy native format which is again a
binary format for you to to save data
between dump I so what I'm doing is I'm
saving the original matrix the dense one
here and then I'm saved as farce 1 and
we can see sorry I'm not blocking at our
dense guy 96 megabytes of zeros they're
all zeros when you use a sparse one 186
kilobytes same exact data your model is
going to perform the same exact way
except you can leave work early right
next point I might be running over time
but I'm the moderator so I can take as
much time as I want next point your
laptop is stronger than you think so
this is again for those people if you
got a computer or whatever and you want
to do more stuff with it
what I find to a lot of the times that
I'll do is I'll go back to that data
sampling point and I'll sample some data
and then develop locally on my laptop
and then I'll deploy that same exact
code to the cloud and because I'm using
a single machine and not a cluster it's
the same exact infrastructure you have a
UNIX environment the same way you have a
UNIX environment on your laptop if you
have a Windows environment on your
laptop throw out your laptop and get a
Mac sorry my opinion only ok next point
use your course so your laptop probably
has 8 cores or it should have at least 8
cores and if it doesn't tell your boss
you can't do your job properly because
you should have a decent computer if
you're working with data and you're
doing things you need to do your job and
if your boss won't get you the laptop
then maybe you're not working in the
right place sorry so but then if you're
like you know I'm sure I'm new to this I
you know I'm trying to get into it I
don't actually have a job where I'm
doing this but invest in a good laptop
because again you want to try to save
yourself some time if you're waiting
hours an hour
for your jobs to finish that's more and
more time that you're gonna waste just
waiting for stuff where you could be
moving on with your career and getting a
new job and you get a tax break or
something I think you could claim it
right if we ever get a tax return this
year who knows so here are some packages
again these two I just added yesterday
because I learned about them yesterday
Rapids doesn't even actually use your
course that uses your GPU but it goes
along with the theme of what I'm saying
top there is is Python multi-processing
is just the regular multi-threading
library inside of Python and then the
bottom is some really handy are packages
that you can look up later
cool success story for this actually at
my company we had this job job that
basically it went through like every
single patient in the data set and did
some like super complex computations and
it was like dealing with longitudinal
data and isn't that it took forever it
took like 12 hours to get for the job to
run and then what was happening is we
would wait 12 hours and then we would
figure out oh something's wrong let's
run it again 12 hours something's wrong
again let's run it again and then
finally I'm like all right enough of
this so sat down a couple hours use the
multi processing package and found out
Wow all you have to do is say map this
function but instead of on one core it
runs on eight cores and then magically
it took 20 minutes and that was amazing
and then everybody loved me and and all
that stuff so it was great so use your
course multi thread stuff some things
can't be multi-threaded some things can
really easily be multi-threaded and
you'll really be amazed at how much time
you're gonna save so now this is just a
couple random tips to close out nothing
gonna meet technical now just again
random ideas that I'm implanting in your
brain don't be patient is my motto I am
NOT a patient person I don't like
waiting for things to finish if it takes
longer than a minute I'm like what's
happening this isn't right
so if it's taking too long you should
optimize it and it's not because you
know you can't wait 20 minutes but what
happens is if you wait 20 minutes for
something you're gonna find a bug you
have to wait 20 minutes again and then
you're gonna bring it to your boss and
he's going to be like mmm can we do this
and this and this and then now it's
going to take three hours but
he added all this functionality to it so
don't be patient if something takes a
long time
you can probably optimize it and if you
can't optimize it on your computer if
you've multi-threaded it already you
can't do it use the cloud so what my
first point so time is money right and
so there's always this trade-off because
like what if you're like okay well the
cloud then I have to pay for that I have
to like rent something and deal with
this the blah blah blah but if five
dollars will send save you a weekend of
waiting for something I think that's
worth it because again you can iterate
on that faster you can provide more
value and you can try more things do
some more cool science so that's my tip
to you again you well if your
multi-threaded if you've done all these
optimizations locally it still is not
very fast take that code throw it on the
cloud should run faster and then my
final tip for all of life generally is
just use the Internet somebody's
probably done this before just google it
or use twitter like at somebody or or
something like that so here's a review
slide of everything we talked about
right starting off with I do think
cluster computing has a place despite
the title of the talk that's just
clickbait to get you in here the cloud
is your friend use your cloud but use
your libraries use the things that you
are familiar with and you will be more
successful because you're you know how
to use them sample your data because you
probably don't need all of it
save in a binary columnar format you
sparse matrices don't be saving zeros
it's not cool
and use your laptop you can probably
optimize things by multi-threading and
using different libraries and using the
Internet so thank you and that's a link
for the code
[Applause]
Aaron questions can you talk about
differences in speed when you're running
some machine learning algorithm when
your data is in RAM on one computer or
in the other case when your data is on a
cluster and you're using some sort of
distributed computing framework how fast
does the actual algorithm run in each
case yeah so what I've done in my own
experience is I will just so even if the
data is stored on a cluster somewhere a
lot of times you'll take that and like
throw it into s3 so basically taking it
out of the cluster and then putting it
into a single file and then I'll pull it
in to the actual you know single machine
but I haven't done any like head-to-head
comparisons on like let me run this
exact algorithm on SPARC and then run
this exact algorithm like on psych it
but what I have found again is more it's
more about the usability I think of it
where you can use a single machine and
try a bunch of different stuff rather
than having to deal with the cluster I
mean I'm making all these claims again I
haven't run a head-to-head comparison
probably go on the internet and find
some things but there might be scenarios
where the cluster will actually could
run it faster especially when you think
about something like a random forest
because then you can just basically put
one tree on each node and then that can
multi thread whatever processing it's
doing in there there are maybe it's in
areas where it's faster but I think with
multi-threading and using multiple cores
it essentially gives you the same it's
the same feeling as having a cluster
because you just have a job on each core
instead you'll need a lot more RAM
because you're basically duplicating all
your data across but I don't have any
exact numbers for you
a question about sparse usage at what
point of sparsity is the threshold for
clearly you're going to be saving memory
the more sparse he or your matrixes but
I've read that if you're at less than
95% sparsity that it's slower
computationally like there's a there's a
computation speed where even if your
data is somewhat sparse you would save
memory but it's slower than if it was
dense do you have any like have any
heuristic recommendation for what level
of sparsity percentage-wise for your
data it makes sense to use sparse
implementations yeah so technically
mathematically the cutoff would be 50%
right because if you have 50% zeroes
then you would use that in practice it's
probably more like 7080 that I've found
because again it's the overhead and
converting it back and forth especially
if you're using libraries or algorithms
that don't support sparse data so a lot
of things like Karis our tensorflow for
example it has to have data in a dense
format so you're paying for those
conversions right you can store your
data and it's still really great that
you can store you don't have to store
the zeros it's smaller on disk but then
when you pull in chunks into memory you
still have to densify it but what I
found just in general practice was
around that 7080 percent we're all
stored in a sparse manner because that
when it becomes cumbersome to do
anything but if it's somewhere like 50
60 it's mostly dense anyway and again at
the end if it's dense you do have more
algorithms available to you so so I
can't learn every single classifier
sports dense data only some of them
supports sparse so if you want to take a
hit on the performance and just save it
in a dense way and if that's doable then
that's still okay because you have more
algorithms available to you similar
question about speed
not compression of the data like if you
have the data and arquette for example
ducks column expresses against that what
kind of penalty do you see so I think
what with a compression most of that is
on disk so once it reads into memory it
should be similar speed so like once you
read the text into memory or you read
the park' into memory so the
computations should be similar don't
quote me on that I might be completely
wrong but one thing that you do pay for
depending on which compression library
is the time it takes to load the data so
at some point generally park' or feather
or whatever it will be faster to load
but at some point if you're using some
really really intense compression
algorithm I run into this with hdf5 you
have different options for compression
algorithms if you use a really really
intense one it's going to take a long
time just to load your data because it
has to transform it into the in-memory
representation so there's usually a good
median of a compression algorithm
that'll give you you know save space for
you but then it won't take too long to
load probably have time for just like
one more okay well you can talk to me
during lunch too so it'll be laughing I
also have a question about sparse data
I looked into using the the pandas
sparse data frame like about a year ago
it seemed it seemed like kind of
neglected and not very well documented
and it wasn't clear to me the underlying
data storage format the way that it is
say with like CSR or CSC from you know
from Sify words like a very standard
sort of format I just I'm curious what
your experiences have been with it and
if you plan to rely on it in the future
I feel like if arrow is the future of
pandas then it it seems like it will
probably follow even further into
neglect because arrow I've read this
spec for arrow and it doesn't seem to me
like sparse data is part of it so what
are your thoughts on how good is your
experience been and deplane to continue
using it sure so I use the sparse data
frames mostly just because I needed to
keep the column names of the matrix and
but basically I had a matrix and then I
had my list of columns and I put them
together to create as far as a different
but I do agree with you it seems like
very neglected part of pandas and it's
still very black box so you're not sure
how it works and it takes a long time
sometimes to do that but I chose to take
that time because I really needed the
column names and with arrow I'm not an
expert on that too but I think it's it's
not necessarily fully gonna replace
pandas but I think it'll change all the
way the operations work an arrow will
just be underneath the hood of Panda so
you should still have the overlaying
data frame that you have but maybe the
way it computes things within the matrix
and the joins and everything would be
pushed down to arrow so I think we're
okay again wes is the expert on that you
can ask him tomorrow but I agree that
the sparse data frame needs a little bit
more love